[Music]
you played this character joey and it's
just because of the show is rerun it was
such a massive hit it was on for so long
and now it's in reruns all around the
world people you know they really like
this character you're lucky that you're
playing such a likable guy you know yeah
i guess it's nicer than playing the
killer all the time people being afraid
you know right no yeah you could have
been playing like a very unlikable
person but you played this guy that
everybody connected to right away and
does that happen to you wherever you go
just you know people are happy to see
you
yes i bring love and joy
no it's funny because um i think
with the the amount of reruns that uh
friends go through
there's a whole new generation that's
discovering the show now and right young
people will come up to me now and say oh
yeah you're joey on friends that's great
wow you're so old
[Laughter]
i find myself using words like scram and
beaded
get out of here
they wonder like why you don't look
exactly the same like your hair's a
little different what's going on yeah
yeah well it's a thing called the
passage of time kid
yeah you know tell me like uh you know
we lived through it because we were on
the same network back in those days and
friends was such a sensation
uh it was it was kind of like a pop
culture
you know happening that friends was so
popular at the craziest what was it like
can you tell us like a
you know like i don't know a story about
just how insane it got when you knew
things were getting out of hand
um
there's a lot of them i remember one
time it sticks out that was uh i was out
to dinner with schwimmer and this must
have been like season two i think we're
at this place over by the beverly center
this i'm not really a fancy place or
anything and this woman
sees david and she has an infant with
her and
she runs over to david and literally
throws the baby
and not like to check and see that he
caught the child just like throws and
she's digging for her camera hello hello
digging for her camera as the baby's in
mid flight
yeah exactly
so thank god schwimmer can catch yeah
that was good that must have been
disturbing yes she didn't notice me at
all
[Applause]
i was like
yes i can catch two
that was the disturbing part now uh you
how old's your daughter she's eight nine
she's eight and and she
uh she does joey's catchphrase she
learned it or she doesn't catch phrases
yeah she's well she does her version of
it you know she says uh how are you
doing
and she won't say it because that's the
way i said it on the show it's not
really the correct way to say it right
right how are you doing right so that's
how she says it and i say that's no
that's not how you say i should say yes
it is
that's not right yes it is this is just
every now and then you two argue about
that that is great that's my catchphrase
that's not how you do daddy knows how to
say it
[Laughter]
what what tv do you find yourself
watching these days like what do you
enjoy watching
um have the stuff that's new that's on
now yeah you know
i spoke about this before this uh
finding bigfoot this show about uh this
is interesting yeah these crazy guys
that run around the woods at night
trying to find bigfoot
and maybe they got canceled because i
can't even find finding bigfoot
i'm not really watching the show itself
is now lost in the woods
they're sending them search party out
for the show
no wait this is a show where they really
are trying to find bigfoot and what
draws you to this show what is it about
this show you know
probably because it's so stupid
that may explain why you're here too no
no this show is
yeah yeah you wouldn't go on finding
bigfoot but you like to watch it but are
you a believer do you believe bigfoot's
out there somewhere
you know i like to
there's this part of me that would love
to believe that this big hairy dude is
running around
in the northwestern united states just
like looking for you know trash or
whatever
eating out of the dumpster
in the noble pursuit of trash
i love that
i also think like all these myths about
a creature that no one can you know i
think in the era of cell phones and
everybody's got a recording device do
you know what i mean and pretty much
land is developed everywhere it's harder
and harder for me to think that bigfoot
exists unless he's driving around in a
car you know exactly and lives in like a
very populated area like in cleveland
you know
right but i guess they discover new
species all the time every year like
about 10
new species around the world that's true
they do that they mostly like you know
amoebas yeah it's like a little amiga
stuff that's easy
a slightly different monkey you know
like
it's not like oh yeah that's seven foot
eight
[Laughter]
it's a monkey with a slightly different
kind of eyebrow